webassembly how many people have heard
of webassembly yet so most people maybe
about half so that's what's kind of cool
so what we're gonna talk about today
we're gonna talk about what webassembly
is I'm gonna try to give some context
around why and why it's important and
then I'm gonna do a demo and we can
actually look at one of the other demos
on webassembly org as well so first of
all to understand why webassembly is
interesting and cool I think it's fun to
kind of like climb back into my Wayback
Machine with me how many people are
doing web development in 1995
okay cool like a few people okay awesome
so in 1995 there was this browser called
Netscape and right it so I did my
internship in college in 1995 at
Nationwide Insurance and I was mostly
doing sequel at sequel server but I kind
of had this side thing where I was
building them to some web stuff and
right during that summer probably in the
spring actually Netscape version I don't
know I want to say 100 maybe it was one
one shipped and Netscape had that
version of Netscape had two new things
in it it had a language called
JavaScript which was brand new and it
turns out written by a guy named Brandon
Naik I want to say in like 10 days and
it had this language that everybody
already knew about which is this
up-and-coming language that was getting
more and more attraction and people were
excited about called Java and at the
time JavaScript was definitely the
afterthought it was like this really
kind of like people saw it and and they
advertised this like kind of almost a
little toy for making your web pages
more interactive but if you wanted to do
like serious hardcore software
engineering in the browser
you wanted Java that was like the tool
that you were supposed to use to do that
and so
it's obviously super interesting that
like nowadays Java and the browser is
dead as a doornail and JavaScript is
like this user group that you're sitting
at so like that's weird what happened
okay
so let's talk about why Java in the
browser failed it made me really sad
because I was like a Java guy man and I
was like all over the java to java for
10 years I ran the Java user group all
the things so I was super sad that it
didn't make it at the browser but
basically why it failed mainly is Java
was like a bolt-on virtual machine that
ran outside of the browser and basically
like you could write Java applets and
they took over this little tiny
rectangle in the middle of your web page
and you could do things there but it was
clearly bolted on and it was clunky and
it was slow and it was like this bolted
on thing and had not real seamless
integration into the web browser in very
late versions of Java you could finally
talk to the rest of the web page from
Java but by that time it was already
almost dead and it was too late so the
idea of Java being a virtual machine in
the browser actually gave us a lot of
the same abilities that webassembly
Willis will see here in a second but it
ultimately failed but the idea of wow
what if we could have a virtual machine
in the browser and we could write
whatever language we want it's actually
not new we tried it once already and
we're like just going in this giant
circle and I just find that like super
super interesting maybe nobody else
cares but anyway let's talk about web
assembly what is web assembly web
assembly according to their website web
assembly or wisdom is a new portable
size and load time efficient format
suitable for compilation for the web
what
what's that mean okay what it really
really actually is and this is why I
thought thought context was cool it's
really a virtual machine for the web
again so what's different this time and
why is it actually going to work so
here's what's different web assembly is
not a Bolton separate virtual machine
where you can execute code it turns out
as JavaScript got more and more mature
rather than this little interpreter that
Brandon Ike wrote in ten days people
optimized JavaScript so it would be
really really fast and in order to do
that they basically had to add a virtual
machine that executes your JavaScript
can do just-in-time compilation
compilation compilation excuse me can
optimize your code and do all sorts of
low-level goodness and magic to make
JavaScript fast enough so all the
browser's at this point in time have
some kind of JavaScript virtual machine
built into them and what web assembly is
doing is exposing the internal browser
VM that's already there so rather than
being a bolt-on we're saying like what
if we could like directly expose the
virtual machine and possibly skip the
fact or not care about the fact that
javascript is the the language that this
virtual machine knows how to execute
natively what if it could execute
whatever language that we want to so I
should have added a slide here how many
people already know what a virtual
machine is okay that's most people that
just for the people that didn't raise
their hands really really quickly when
you write computer programs you compile
those computer programs in whatever
language that you wrote them in down
into machine language zeros and ones
that your CPU that little chip inside
your laptop can execute
if you have a different kind of chip you
need to compile it I can omit the right
kind of instructions for whatever kind
of computer chip that is a virtual
machine is basically an idea which says
that what if instead of compiling into
actual machine instructions that can
execute on whatever CPU I have what if I
made up this pretend computer that had a
set of instructions that I define and I
compile into this pretend machine
language the advantages that this
pretend machine language it's easier to
translate that at the lower level into
the actual machine language and so
that's the idea and it also makes it
really easy to make a compiler once that
can compiles into a some pretend machine
language format and I don't have to
write a separate compiler for every
different kind of computer chip that's
on the market that's the basic idea of
the virtual machine so that said
exposing that means I can write in
whatever programming language I want the
other thing that's different this time
is cross browser support so web assembly
like I couldn't believe this actually
happens when I saw it happen but web
assembly is actually there's commitment
to support across Chrome Firefox and ie
Chrome as you might guess Chrome and
Firefox are done and edge is still
coming along but there's actually like
official support across all the browsers
to be able to support it so that's right
what's that
oh yeah Safari - sorry my bad I assume
edge becomes IE eventually I don't know
I don't know how it works
yeah I'm sure it's like the future the
future Microsoft browser or whatever is
whatever they call it I have trouble
keeping track of all those things but
the point is like the Microsoft browser
platform will also adopt this as
and it's like underway with it the other
thing that's really really important is
it does have well-defined J s bindings
so when you build something in web
assembly you can talk to it
and execute things from JavaScript it's
a it's as we'll see it's a pretty clean
easy to work with a layer of talking
between the two and that's that's what
I'll demo that's what what we'll look at
together in code so why would you want
to do this so first of all I think it's
really cool to be able to execute
languages other than javascript in the
browser thanks miles
obviously this is a Java users group so
like yeah that's the thing and I'm not
here to talk trash on JavaScript but I
like freedom of choice as a developer I
want to be able to choose what I want to
use to do whatever I'm doing when it
comes right down to it Java scripts got
a ton better and maybe I'll keep
choosing it but like not having to I
think is awesome also there's some
definite performance benefits that was
in promises and especially if you're
doing things like hardcore 3d graphics
whatever in the browser being able to
optimize code by dropping down to a
lower level languages interesting so is
it ready yet kind of we'll see like what
are the things that are good now and we
can do and what are the things that are
like stay tuned coming soon so what can
I do right now I can execute plasm
format so wasm format is like a binary
format of these imaginary machine
language instructions basically I think
it's a little higher level abstraction
than that but I don't go look at the
binaries to see what they are I'm not
that interested
so browsers right now like Chrome
right now today stock chrome can just
execute blossom I didn't have to go to
Crenn Erik canary to do it I didn't have
to turn any chrome flags on I just
brought up my wasum demo and poof it
works so that's pretty cool and I'm
pretty sure Firefox is the same way
there are compilers that can emit wasm
that binary format and the key one is
LLVM which is a kind of a virtual
machine compiler back-end I'm not an
LLVM expert but it's basically like a
compiler back-end that lots and lots of
languages use and so rust is the example
language I'm going to look at rust using
LLVM can compile into this wasm format
so the two languages that you can
actually practically do stuff with in
wasm so far the ones that I can find
working examples for our C and rust how
many people have heard of rust at all
okay so most people actually that's
pretty cool so rust is a it's I think
it's mainly like a systems level
programming language that Mozilla came
up with and it's a pretty low-level
language designed to write operating
systems and things at that level it's
basically it snitches to be a more
productive c c is like a really old
school language been around forever and
rust is trying to fill that same Nicias
c so it's it's pretty low level you can
do things like memory management
yourself in rust and see yeah you got to
do memory management yourself so they're
both pretty low level languages and it
might occur to you and it certainly did
to me like why do i am i limited to such
low level languages why why why aren't
all the languages in the world just like
jumping on this and building compilers
that Amit wasn't I will answer that
question in just a
but let's go ahead and jump in and do a
demo so I thought it was really cool to
actually do true language choice
I don't know Russ at all so I'm just
sort of like stumbling around but I got
a demo and was able to actually write
some of my own Russ code and see it
actually work in the browser so I
thought it'd be really cool to see that
so let's jump into the code and then
I'll actually run it cuz the demo is
frankly the least exciting bit sadly but
let's start with a file of rust so for
those that haven't seen rust hopefully
this is I don't know what I'm doing
either but this was mostly self
explanatory Mew - what's that font bump
is that what you said how's that
everybody able to read that okay cool so
like most languages I start with a main
function this main function is what gets
executed when my wasm module loads from
the browser it knows how to translate
print line which is like the internal
like puts their system.out.print line of
rust it actually sends that to the
console it knows how to do that much and
then I'm defining two functions add and
multiply that are self-explanatory I
think rust is a typed language so I have
to tell it my parameters and my return
value are all in 32s something else
that's interesting probably or at least
I'll give you a little context these are
all like take numbers and return a
number type function I actually tried
and wanted to say like oh I think it
would be cool to do some string
manipulation I'd like a little hello
function that took a string and return a
string actually working with strings in
rust and then sending them back to the
browser turns out to be non
trivial because I'm not yet an expert
enough with memory management in rust to
know that like a string well I don't
know how many bytes that is ahead of
time I gotta allocate the right amount
of memory and then I got a deal with
sending that back into the browser and
that was like too hard for me to do so
like literally writing a HelloWorld
function was required more brain power
than they had I had in the hours that I
spent at it yesterday so that gives you
an idea for like what level we're at
right now we're like way down here so
I'll talk about like how that's gonna
get better here soon in a little bit but
right now yeah the only thing I was
smart enough to do I started with AD and
I created multiply myself so yeah not
not super rocket science II there so
that's what the rust file looks like I
am cheating a little bit let's look at
my index J s file well I'll start with
index dot HTML so I'm using webpack how
many people are web pack familiar a
little bit so web map is a bundling tool
that takes care of like bringing all my
JavaScript together in one file
maybe transpiling from one javascript
version to another lots of like plumbing
type work there is a web pack plugin
which runs the rust compiler and builds
my executable for me already so
basically all I had to do is start with
the example project and as we can see
here in my JavaScript I can actually
require rust files and use them and web
pack knows how to do all the work for me
to be able to make that happen so this
require actually web pack is taking care
of the details of running the rust
compiler on this file emitting a wasm
binary format
we can see it over here yeah it's not so
readable it's binary but there it is
anyway so webpack takes care of running
the RUS compiler outputting the right
thing when i make changes and the way I
interact with it through JavaScript
looks like this I'm using require which
webpack gives me and getting to this
wasm module it's also given me a few
shortcuts to the wasm api if I was using
the raw web assembly API I would have to
do a little bit more work but not a lot
I'm calling initialize I am passing this
flag I actually had to add this when I
first started working with this demo it
didn't work what happened was I would
load my functions but by the time I
tried to execute them the run time would
have executed would have exited and it
would tell me that runtimes no longer
around you can't execute that function
anymore which was kind of awkward so I
had to pass this extra flag in here to
tell it hey don't let the runtime exit
execute please because I want to
actually be able to use those functions
anyway seems a little silly but that's
what I had to do
so this initialize actually like fires
up the wazoo stuff and it returns a
promise where my wasm module gets passed
to me after it's loaded
this module is what contains the
executable rough stuff and how I bridge
that executable rough stuff into
JavaScript is with functions on that
module object and the only function that
I'm using here is called C wrap I don't
know why it's called C wrap I I guess
that gives you a feel for like hey it's
designed to be talking to see mostly I
presume that's the case in my case I am
actually wrapping a rust function so
it'd be nice if it was called something
else but never mind I am wrapping an ad
function and I need to tell it all the
type information so that's important
when we're going from like totally
different environments one to the now
the other somehow the system has to know
how to map types from one environment to
types in another environment and the
JavaScript primitive types it knows how
to do that with in this case I'm just
using number that's it I had issues with
string like I said
so this says hey this function returns a
number and then that last argument is
the parameters I have two in there both
numbers so I get back a function a
JavaScript function from that module C
wrap call and then finally once all
that's done I'm able to just invoke
those functions as if they were
JavaScript because effectively they are
so just so you can actually see this is
working let's actually change this to
lie and we'll just like multiply a times
a times B and in my code over here now
it should be 18 instead of six did I get
my arithmetic right I hope so
thanks Dan okay so I have the server
running in that project over here I have
a compiled task that just runs webpack
on it and so if I do npm run compile we
can actually see it do its thing you can
see it actually compiles that rust file
okay npm run serve
and now if I go back here and reload
this hello world we can see that it
actually outputs hello world
says I'm calling Russ functions from
JavaScript outputs the result of add and
the result of our multiply which is a
lie so it actually works I can actually
execute Russ compiled code in my browser
I know it's not visually cool but for me
like as it the implications of it are
pretty exciting and yeah that's my tempo
such as it is let's see so I promised
like there was a question that I'd get
back to you and that is like why can't I
use higher-level languages like Ruby and
crystal and whatever whatever or
whatever and it turns out there's some
features that higher-level languages
expect from their runtime the principle
ones are a garbage collector if you
think about a language like Ruby you
never have to allocate memory yourself
you just make objects willy nilly and
there's this thing called the garbage
collector that keeps track of who's
using those objects and if nobody's
using those objects that cleans up that
memory for you so that you don't run out
of it the other Oh memory management you
know that's a typo I'm sorry garbage
collector and memory management that's
just different ways of saying the same
thing the other bullet point should have
been threading that's the other thing
that most modern runtimes expect you to
be able to have or most higher-level
languages expect out of their runtime is
the ability to do threads so those are
the features needed by languages here's
the complete list of feature those
features that are supported by web
assembly currently as you can see there
aren't any however what's cool is all of
those things are actively on the roadmap
and if we I should have actually left a
link to this over here but if you
actually go
and find some of these features you can
actually yeah host MVP features document
so all of these things so right now
we're WebP assembly at is that is the
MVP has just now shipped and been
declared like done we're done with the
MVP and the MVP is just like can we
execute plasm code and the browser and
we saw that happen and we can do that
the next things are like how do i build
out this platform so that I could
support higher level languages as you
can see there the key bits that we're
gonna need garbage collection and
threads are underway right now and if
you want to if you track through these
issues you can actually go find that
there get repositories with code and
them for a lot of them and people
actually working on that stuff so that's
pretty cool it's low level now probably
not practical for a widespread use but I
am I'm optimistic that it's gonna get
there so oh I already did that oh I
didn't mean to say that yeah so that's
kind of the future these things are
coming along they're being supported
cross-browser I think the future for a
web assembly is really really bright
there are some free go to the web
assembly page like the demo is actually
pretty cool it's actually like a full
unity game that they have ported to
output wasm code so like this is like
not you know this is just a little bit
better than my demo just like that much
but this is running a full 3d game using
wasm I haven't actually tried it yet
hopefully it works
I didn't verify that seems like it's
starting okay
yes doing something oh you can't hear
the little silly sounds that it's
playing oh look I've got a little tank I
bet I can shoot stuff
uh which one is mine I'm moving the red
tank but when I press the space part the
blue tank shoots so yeah maybe they've
got some issues to work out there I
guess but it's still like using unity
which is what real game developers use
and it actually works so yeah that's
kind of my schpeel any uh any questions
on web assembly
I'm most excited about language
independence so I see languages maybe
not Ruby but I think it's more likely a
language like crystal which is very
closely related to Ruby and uses LLVM I
think crystal will might be one of the
first ones that I'd be interested in
because I think it already uses LLVM any
languages that are based on LLVM I bet
you it will ship first
so pearl actually might be one of the
first ones believe it or not two pearls
the one that springs to mind I'm pretty
sure Perl 6 is all a VM base I don't
know does anybody else know of any I
mean obviously rust crystal I I could
look it up but there's probably quite a
few anything else or any other questions
I mean alright well that's kind of all I
got
next month hopefully I hope you hearing
about view Jas and if you want to talk
about webassembly or anything I'll hang
out here for a few minutes thanks
everybody